welcome to the afternoon session I am
right away all right so first up we have
P J he will talk about rizar algebra
for thank thank you very much Rachel um
so I should say that the talk is going
to actually be more about interior Point
methods and essentially how they perform
when you are allowed approximate
solutions to the system of linear
equations that underlies interior Point
methods as opposed to randomized linear
algebra which is my favorite topic but
on the other hand the tools we're going
to use in this talk from randomized
linear algebra are going to be fairly
straightforward and actually known for a
while so we're going to blackbox some
things we're going to make them play
nice for interior Point methods but
really most of the work has been on
understanding interior Point methods
under noisy uh updates basic so I should
start by saying acknowledging the
collaborators uh so this is Joint work
it's a few papers actually uh joint work
over the past two three years with himim
aam from the University of Tel Aviv uh
agniva was my PhD student he did most of
this work during his post at orl Gregory
Dexter is still my PhD student and Palma
London from Caltech at the times she's
now UCSD was visiting us uh talking to
us about this
l so this a crowd that I don't really
need to talk about motivation why we
care about continuous optimization I
will say that compared to all the
difficult problems seen over the past
couple of days here about non-convex
optimization and what not I'm looking at
the simplest possible case I'm looking
at linear programming very convex very
well behaved and for me I should say
this started I was trying to do L1
regression on genomic data and the
genomic data I had access to was really
large like think of a matrix with half a
million rows two to three million
columns dense Matrix so I wanted to do
L1 regression there and um it's a linear
program but it didn't scale well of
course so I wanted sketching based
faster algorithms for this particular
setting uh turned out that this was not
kind of the right thing to do because
there were better models what is called
a linear mixed model lmm for this
particular data so we followed the
different approach but at the same time
uh it got us thinking about linear
programming and what we can do with
linear programming uh and interior Point
methods so on one hand of course
continuous optimization is important in
pretty much all of machine learning but
also because relax many combinatorial
optimization programs uh problems to uh
linear programs uh Matrix sketching you
know we've been working on this for
almost a quarter of a century now uh and
uh we understand how you can essentially
create a sketch of a matrix that
consists maybe of a few rows a few
columns a few elements or multiply a
matrix by a random gaussian Matrix or
something like that and create the
sketch and we understand that this works
well in many settings also the qu the
the topic here was of course to sort of
combine the two now interior Point
methods as we will discuss are iterative
optim a iterative algorithm so you need
to see how the error propagates over
iterations and that's pretty much what
we're going to do the standard setting I
know you've been through tutorials here
in the boot camp week I actually watched
those tutorials they were really nice uh
both for uh things like linear
programming as well as for Matrix
sketching but I will repeat some of the
material to make sure we are on the same
page stand form for LP Primal dual you
are looking at a minimization problem
subject to axal b x being non negative
this is your a primal variable I want to
think of this as an as a being an M byn
Matrix so my Primal variable is n
dimensional the Dual problem of course B
transpose y a maximization problem now
uh subject to the Dual constraint which
includes the Dual variable y this is an
M dimensional variable and the slack
variable
s uh which is n dimensional now Y is not
constrainted but s is s has to be non
negative as well and we know that
because of a strong Duality uh we get
that the Primal optimal C transpose X
and B transpose Y at optimality of
course the match and kind of picture
here of course a simple polytop uh I
have six constraints two dimensions and
the optimal solution always at the
vertex but the methods we are going to
be exploring interior Point methods they
don't look at
vertices don't much about the
applications appears everywhere here's
our objective my objective was to look
at kind of textbook approaches so I
wanted to look at very practical
algorithms as I said in the beginning my
focus was genomic data but uh it could
be applied
elsewhere I wanted to look at interior
Point methods because they are the
technique of choice in practice
now interior Point methods if you know a
little bit about the history for linear
programming they came of course after
Simplex they came after the ellipsoid
interior Point methods in the beginning
there were the long step the short step
ones and then you got predictor
corrector which are very good both in
theory and in practice they achieve the
same run in time guarantees as short
step methods but they also have the
Practical efficiency if you will of
longstep
methods I wanted so I wanted to analyze
kind of the predictor Rector the
standard ipms the ones that are in some
sense used in practice as well and I
wanted to use iterative linear solvers
things like preconditioned conjugate
gradients instead of uh you know more
exotic tools like Fast matrix
multiplication because this is something
that in practice probably would not work
so well I also wanted to have efficient
preconditioner constructions that's
where the randomized linear algebra is
going to come into play instead of
mechanisms like inverse maintenance
which again how practical they are
um remains I think to be seen and we
wanted to be able to extend the
classical theoretical convergence
guarantees for interior Point methods
for linear programs when we use inexact
linear system sols okay and there was
work of course in this area before and I
think we're able to get some uh newer
bounds here as
well just as a reminder the optimality
conditions we're going to look at the
Primal problem and the Dual problem at
the same time so we're going to solve
them both X Primal variable y the Dual
variable s is the slack and remember
that X Ys is a primal dual optimal
solution if it is basically Primal
feasible this is Primal feasibility dual
feasible this is dual feasibility they
need to be no negative and the last
condition is the complementary slackness
which I don't particularly like this
notation but what it basically says is
that either XI the Primal or a side the
slack they have to be zero at optimality
so one of the two has to be zero at
least one of the two has to be zero
now for reasons for those of you who
work in randomized linear algebra you're
going to recognize why I'm doing this uh
we're going to focus on problems where
the constraint Matrix a is either tall
and thin so you have a lot more
constraints than variables or short and
fat so you have a lot fewer uh so you
have a small number of constraints a lot
of variables or it has exact low rank so
for General Square mates I cannot do
much and this is because I cannot design
good preconditioners for those matrices
using the tools that I have at my
disposal a special case would be laan
matrices symmetric diagonally dominant
more General but I'm not going to go get
to that at all so tall and th short and
fat exact low rank at this point you
could add a little bit of noise and that
would work but you know don't we're not
going to worry about
this standard methods of course Simplex
is probably the first thing that comes
to mind fasting practice exponential
worst time uh exponential time worst
case complexity interior Point method ID
skipping interior Point methods they are
the fastest they're fast in theory um
weak polinomial time convergence they
are often faster in practice than large
scale lpce um in the as I was working in
this area I talked to people at gurobi
and other places and they told me that
in many cases they will run an interior
Point method uh to get close to the
optimal solution but then they would
switch to Simplex to actually get the
actual optimal solution so combination
of the methods also exist I like this
picture just because it gives you an
idea of how interior Point methods
operate for linear programming and kind
of the important thing is that you go
through basically the middle of the
polytop or certainly the center of the
polytop you follow approximately what is
called the central path here until you
get close to basically an optimal
solution which will lie in a Vertex
potentially you get Epsilon close this
is the Epsilon neighborhood of the
solution we'll give some definitions in
a minute and this is um in some sense
what interior Point methods do now we'll
look at another another picture to show
what predictor corrector methods do
that's kind of the textbook presentation
and what you look you look at The
Duality measure so you look at the
distance between the Primal Optimum and
the Dual Optimum this is the Primal the
mean this is the Dual the Max and when
it gets to zero you know that you've
reached of course optimality it's
exactly equal to X transpose s this is
just a one line
thing and in Primal dual
ipms the idea is to follow this Central
path here now the central path satisfies
x i s i equal to Mu for some parameter
mu this is the centrality parameter but
this is not easy uh of course you are
not going to be able to satisfy that in
every iteration so you are going to just
be close to that and I'm using here an
L2 Norm definition of the neighborhood
there are other definitions as well
where you're trying to get x i s i minus
mu sum the squares of those differences
the two Norm basically to be smaller
than sum Theta time mu and that's the
neighborhood how do you compute updates
so interior Point methods they're
iterative methods you have a current
itate you move to the next itate to find
the next itate you compute the So-Cal
Newton Direction and it solves the
system of linear equations now you can
break this up I do want to highlight one
thing if you look at the first line this
line here that has a and zeros and then
Delta X Delta y Delta s these are the
Primal update the Dual update the slack
update you're going to see that a Delta
X the other two of course cancel out has
to be equal to zero this is telling you
that Delta X the update on the X
Direction has to be in the null space of
a and that's to ensure visibility
basically and this is fundamental in the
proofs of ipms for for interior Point
methods for linear programming you can
sort of uh play with these equations a
bit and you can get this system of
equations this is nice this first
equation is the so-call normal equations
here's what you get you get a d square a
transpose d square depends on the
current iterate values X size and size
and S size basically D is just X the
half s to the minus half where X
contains the it's a diagonal matrix that
contains the XI s is a diagonal matrix
that contains the SI the slack this is
symmetric positive definite so you like
this of course on the other hand this
could be quite ill condition especially
as you approach convergence this is the
system you need to solve if you follow
the normal equation path you need to
solve this system to get Delta y then
Delta s and Delta X are what we call
matx they are easy to compute they is no
system to solve here you just do some
Matrix Vector multiplications and that's
it so all the work is basically here
we're going to focus on this I'm going
to present an alternative approach the
augmented uh path approach in the bit as
well predictor corrector so if you want
to think about predictor corrector
algorithms they iterative algorithms
they take two step they take the solve
two systems of linear equations at each
step there is a predictor step and a
corrector step the predictor step what
it does it takes you a little bit
further away from the center so it
doesn't really follow it's not it
doesn't lie in a good enough
neighborhood perhaps but on the other
hand it makes good progress towards the
objective and then in the corrector step
you get back to the close neighborhood
to get good performance so it combines
the good things from long step methods
step methods that make good progress
with short step methods that at Le
theoretically converge
faster so predictor corrector takes
these two steps in the
analysis here where we're going to focus
so we want to solve this system a sare a
transpose Delta y equal to some right
hand side p and the question is how do
we solve it if you solve it with direct
solvers that's a standard analysis what
if you throw in like a an iterative
solver and get back an approximate
solution so what happens you lose
visibility you lose various things and
the question is can you still prove
something and this question has been
around for a while now the result I'm
going to describe I don't think I've
seen it as such in the literature this
is for predictor corrector methods it
says the following that as long as you
satisfy these two constraints if you are
familiar with numerical linear algebra
this is a forward and a backward error
constraint so the first constraint is
saying get an approximate solution Delta
y Tilda so that Delta y Tilda minus the
exact solution with respect to the
energy Norm is at most Delta
so this is basically saying that your
approximate solution minus the exact
solution is small is good enough and
then you have a residual constraint as
well which is saying that if you hit
your original matrix by the approximate
solution minus the right hand side if
you solve it exactly that would be zero
it's all going to be zero it has to be
less than or equal to Delta as long
these two things are satisfied this is
with respect to the energy Norm this is
just the two Norm uh you are going to be
able to get the guarantees of the
standard predictor corrector algorithm
as long as Delta is sufficiently small
so you get the iteration complexity of
the standard predictor corrector which
is order root n n is the number of
variables Times log 1 / Epsilon where
Epsilon is the neighborhood size that
you want to converge to notice the
logarithmic convergence of course which
is what you want to get and approximate
Solutions can be tolerated as long as
the error is less than Epsilon the
neighborhood divided by the square root
of n this sounds small but iterative
methods can get this kind of convergence
guarantees pretty much in time that is
logarithmic uh in this error
here however the final solution will be
uh not be exactly feasible it will be
Epsilon feasible you lose visibility and
you need to be a little bit careful in
the analysis to make sure that uh this
loss of visibility does not propagate in
a bad way so this was kind of the first
result we got I think I I I suspect that
some variant of this result should be
known to numerical analysts because in
practice that's what everybody does they
don't solve the system exactly they use
some iterative method to solve
it here's the next thing that we try to
do is there a way to actually
approximately solve the system and still
somehow get a final solution that is
exactly feasible is it possible to
correct for that error so that got us
thinking along the lines of can we
somehow take this approximate solution
Delta y Tilda and fix it so that the
system uh so that the the the the next
itate is exactly feasible and can we
analyze this so This the result that we
got we introduced a new vector v v is
going to be n dimensional again this is
going to be under your control so you
control
V you're going to get an approximate
solution Delta y TAA you get to control
V and Delta white TAA has to satisfy now
this new equality and there are various
ways to State this equality but for now
now let me state it as is it has a it
has s inverse which is the diagonal
matrix of the slack variables times V
you compute Delta XA just like before
you don't change anything and you fix
Delta X thilda by putting a little bit
of a correction here this guarantees now
that Delta X thilda is lying in the null
space of a you control V you come up
with some approximate solution Delta y
Tilda but they have to be connected in
this way
and I like this I like this a lot
because when I saw this I realized that
you know now you can go back to the
standard analysis it doesn't exactly
work but it almost works and you could
back go back to the original analysis
and guarantee of course visibility at
the end and make your life a little bit
simpler and then we found a very similar
idea in a fairly old paper actually as I
was giving this stock in front of the
optimizing crowd FR of the optimizers
they pointed me to this paper by Monon
and donil which had a very similar idea
but could not construct V in a good way
in an efficient
here's a structural result the
structural result is same get an in
exact solution Delta y anything you
want get a vector v again anything you
want this is going to be under your
control the only constraint is that this
equality has to be satisfied and the two
Norm of V has to be order Epsilon
Epsilon is the target
accuracy then you are not going to lose
anything in terms of convergence you
lose a constant here actually but that's
all you lose so predict corrector is
going to converge in the same number of
iterations basically with the
approximate solution as long as you do
this correction final solution is
exactly feasible you don't lose
visibility either and it's up to you how
to construct V so you control that I'll
give a construction of V that's where
randomized numerical linear algebra will
come in it's not the most elegant one I
don't think it's the most elegant
construction uh but it's a construction
that is faster that is fast enough for
our purposes at
least this is a structural resol by the
way there is nothing randomized here
this is just structural
result um I was giv this talk a couple
of months ago in front of a g of
optimizers and Jess gonio pointed me to
this paper of his where they are not
solving uh the normal equations they are
looking at the so-called augmented
system which is this system here it's
equivalent to the previous one but they
solve this system for Delta y Tilda and
Delta X still at the same time uh it's
worth noting that when they do
approximate solvers for this system here
they still want to emphasize that a
Delta xtia is equal to zero so they
force Delta xtia to lie in the null
space of a we tolerate noise there and
we correct it unlike what was done in
previous work for the augmented system
but the claim is that for certain uh
instances using specialized trial of
solvers and some special preconditioners
they're actually able to make this
happen in practice so I just wanted to
put up that reference as well for an
alternative way to think about this
problem how can we solve the linear
system while satisfying the previous
conditions and I'm going to be wrapping
up in a couple minut in a few minutes
precondition conjugate gradient again of
the self approaches uh the
preconditioner for those of you who are
uh doing randomized linear algebra what
we are doing if we think of a short and
fat Matrix a * D will be M by n n much
larger than M you sketch it so you
compute ADW and you use that you run an
SVD or you could do a QR as well and you
use that as your preconditioner
basically forget about the math um this
has been done actually for over a decade
at this point in randomized linear
algebra it's very similar to blend a
piic what him AB has done very similar
to lsrn what Michael Mahoney has done so
we sort of know how to do this uh
properly and then you iteratively solve
it you use uh we had to prove a couple
of results for preconditioned conjugate
gradient but nothing particularly new as
far as I can tell at least uh as long as
your preconditioning is good enough uh
it conver is exponentially fast to the
right solution so you get the bonds that
you want to
get skip that let me talk about this uh
so essentially all we need to do is to
run a precondition conjugate graded
method for log n / Epsilon iterations
this is the inner iteration so you have
the outer iteration of the IPM that's
root 10 log 1/ Epsilon forget about the
MU the inner iteration runs for another
log n / Epsilon for the precondition
conjugate but the preconditioner has to
be good enough uh no dependency on any
kind of condition numbers for the ad
Matrix you get rid of all that because
your preconditioner is good uh the
correction Vector so you have to
construct the correction Vector the
construction is this ugly thing here
this is reverse engineered this worked
for us that's how we basically did it
but one has to say that um this is free
all the running time that you need to
spend is done in the construction of the
preconditioner once you have your
precond conditioner this is literally
two or three M so it comes for free
because of the construction of the
preconditioner I'm pretty sure there are
alternative ways to construct this uh
vector v uh we haven't looked at
that run time
complexity so if you want to solve the
system of linear equations exactly again
we're not doing matrix multiplication
time and things like that m sare n time
assume that m is smaller than n so
that's the time that you're going to
spend if is large this could be too
large so we get rid of n essentially and
this is the uh relevant thing here every
iteration using this in exact solves
will take M Cube plus input sparity time
that's because we use of course Subspace
embedding the projections uh that
basically can be applied in input
spacity time and again a lot of this is
sort of vanilla randomized linear
algebra but you make it to play with an
iterative procedure
here
okay let me wrap up and talk about a
couple of open problems which I think
would be interesting from a theoretical
and a practical perspective uh so we
provide structural conditions that have
nothing to do with randomized linear
algebra under which in exactly Computing
the predictor corrector steps which
means solving the system of linear
equations inexactly uh you are able to
still return a final solution that is
approximately feasible without losing
anything in terms of iteration
complexity and we provideed way to
correct for the error that you incur and
in correcting for this error you end up
with an exactly feasible solution again
without losing anything in terms of
iteration complexity and you are able to
sort of eliminate to a certain extent uh
n the number of variables uh from uh the
uh complexity from from the running time
complexity future work so uh all these
are for what is called the feasible
predictor corrector meaning that you
start with a feasible solution if you
start with an INF feasible solution
there is a recent paper that analyzes
predictor corrector for infusible
predictor correctors I mean it would be
a technical thing to actually generalize
some of these things to INF feasible
predictor corrector
ipms I don't know if we can get simpler
structural condition so the results that
I showed you are sufficient I don't know
if they are necessary I don't know if we
could do better there the most
interesting thing I think from a
practical perspective especially and a
theoretical perspective perhaps would be
to understand if the structural
condition could change as we iterate so
right now I have the same structural
condition over all
iterations however it is totally
plausible that early on you need more or
less accuracy I guess and later on you
could perhaps work on a GPU so these
days remember we have CPUs and gpus
maybe some of the operations can be done
on a CPU high accuracy some of the
operations can be delegated to gpus that
operate on half Precision or something
it would be good to understand at which
point in the iteration of let's say an
IPM you can actually make that switch uh
this is sometimes called the dynamic
preconditioning maybe you are going to
create a preconditioner that is less
accurate or more accurate as the
iterations
go and of course you could go beyond
potentially ipms are also useful Beyond
linear programs you could look at sem
def programs you could look at quadratic
programs um and see if some of those
approaches will be useful as we okay
going to wrap it up here and leave a few
minutes for questions thank you
[Applause]
any
questions yes should I bring the mic
over thanks so I was just going to ask
about what happens with PCG as your
approach termination because your in
your systems can become very conditions
right at that point so in theory it
doesn't matter I mean because I
precondition so it works well and my
precondition is guaranteed to bring the
condition number down to a constant so
in theory it doesn't matter in practice
I didn't show any experiments here but
in practice obviously we observed that
as we approach optimality when the
conditioning actually worsens we did
have to get better sketches in the prec
condition but we didn't have to run the
PCG for more iterations if that's what
you're woring about like how large are
those how large are those
systems uh we looked at toy systems I
didn't look at the systems that I
started with so I looked at you know
synthetic problems maybe 10 you know 100
by 10,000 things like that I never
looked at L large problems
thanks is I think this relates to
Adrian's question which is like is there
you're just looking at error in the
solves but there's for example you're
assuming you can solve your precondition
system exactly which like given that
it's probably itself ill conditioned you
probably can't do like could you do like
an error analysis of the whole thing or
yeah so no we did not try that yeah we
thought about this with time what
happens if your preconditioning is not
really computed exactly right that's
what you're I guess what I mean is like
you you have a preconditioner which you
know provably gives you a good precond
conditioner but therefore it must be a
condition towards the end of that like a
I don't remember what the Matrix ADW
must be ill conditioned eventually
uh aw is ill condition for sure because
ad is ill condition and the problem is
that when you invert that you are in
trouble right now we're not yeah in the
analysis we're not taking so you're kind
of assuming that's exact okay absolutely
it's the same as blend and pick lsrn
they all make the same ass yeah with
black but it would be cool to analyze
that no you're absolutely right that
would be cool regardless that would be
cool in the context of blender because
abely you
correct all right in the interest of
time uh we're gonna let's thank uh show
us one more
time